bonjour je m'appelle steve kaufmann
steve kaufmann
pour ceux qui ne me connaissent pas je
fais souvent des vidéos ici en anglais
sur l'apprentissage des langues
donc j'en parle 22e et j'avais promis de
faire des vidéos un an langues autres
que l'anglais est donc je commence avec
le français j'ai a écrit un article sur
mon blog vous verrez le lien dans la
description kit est un peu le même sujet
que je vais aborder dans cette vidéo il
c'est la motivation dans la bande à
l'apprentissage des langues et surtout
je vais faire référence à trois
questions qui ont été posées dans une
vidéo dans la série ted t&d et par un
certain professeur scott gains et il dit
que pour en ce qui concerne l'autre ce
qu'il appelle certes mode veille
c'est-à-dire l'auto motivation il ya
trois questions qu'il faut se poser
premier et je crois que cela a beaucoup
de résidences s'applique très bien à
l'apprentissage des langues
première question est ce que je suis
capable de le faire
la tâche est ce que je suis capable de
compléter la tâche donc en ce qui
concerne l'apprentissage des langues
est ce que je suis capable de me
transformer en une personne qui sache
parler une autre langue couramment
c'est la question et je dois avouer que
avant que j'ai appris le français
jusqu'à un niveau je dirais plus ou
moins convenable
je n'avais pas cette confiance parce que
je l'avais pas déjà fait mais je dois
dire que après avoir appris le français
j'avais cette confiance je savais que je
pouvais le faire et quand j'ai
j'avais faim il me fallait apprendre le
chinois parce que c'était mon travail où
j'ai le gouvernement canadien
j'étais tout à fait confiant que je
pouvais le faire et je crois que pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais appris une autre
langue
il faut il faut accepter le fait qu'on
puisse le faire a il faut et comme on
dit en anglais
il faut se donner la bénéfice de 2 du
doute
il faut accepter qu'on puisse le faire
parce que s'ils font n'importe quelle
tâche n'importe quel but qu'on se donne
que ce soit un voyage
si on croit pas qu on va arriver à notre
destination
vaut mieux ne pas entreprendre le voyage
si on grimpe sur une colline au gré de
l'alpinisme
si on croit pas qu'on peut atteindre le
sommet vaut mieux ne pas commencer dont
il faut accepter il faut croire qu'on
peut faire ce qu'on préfère qu'on peut
atteindre son but ça c'est la première
question est ce qu'on peut le faire
la réponse c'est oui deuxième question
est ce que ça va marcher
c'est à dire est ce que la méthode que
j'utilise est la bonne
est ce que c'est une heure méthode est
efficace et là aussi si l' on ne croit
pas à sa méthode il faut changer de
méthode
pour ma part je préconise toujours une
méthode qui est basée sur la lecture et
l'écoutent et surtout de choses qui sont
intéressantes
qu'est-ce que je dois dire là dessus
c'est l'expérience que j'ai eue en
apprenant beaucoup de langues
si on met l'emphase sur la compréhension
et l'acquisition de vocabulaire on
s'accoutume et la langue on s'accoutume
à s'accoutumer les manières d'expression
de cette langue
l'esprit de cette langue et comme a dit
montaigne parce que je veux les écouter
les essais de montaigne ne par michel
piccoli et c'est très très bien et
randonnée montagne
il raconte un essai dans la section sur
l'institution des enfants et il dit
enfin il cite sénèque qui dit si les
choses enfin je cite pas mémoire si les
choses ont bien pénétrer l'esprit les
mots foisonnent donc à bonn il ya une
abondance de mots et c'est exactement le
sentiment que j'ai eu une fois que
j'arrive à comprendre la langue baiata
de mots et d'expressions qui foisonnent
dans mon esprit et quand je commence à
parler petit activée je vais transformer
ses connaissances peut-être passive en
mots et expressions active que je peux
utiliser
donc ça c'est ma méthode à moi mais il
faut que chacun choisisse une méthode
qui convient à lui ou elle
il ya des gens qui veulent parler dès le
début pour moi ça n'a aucun sens parce
que je ne veux pas vrai que cargèse
j'ai assez de mots pour m'exprimer et
quand je peux comprendre que dit l'autre
mais à chacun de choisir
donc il faut répondre oui ça va marcher
la méthode c'est la bonne et la
troisième question est ce que c'est en
vaut la peine
là aussi si vous passez que
apprendre une langue ça prend du temps
ça prend beaucoup d'efforts au début on
a des contenus et peu intéressant c'est
difficile et un thermos qu'on doit
apprendre et oublier apprendrez oublier
quand on commence à parler on fait
beaucoup de fautes
et tout ça alors pour pourquoi infligée
toutes ces peines
si c'est un mot c'est ça n'en vaut pas
la peine donc il faut être convaincu ça
c'est en va en vaut la peine
et dans mon cas évidemment ça vaut la
peine ça m'a beaucoup aimé
dans mes affaires donc
professionnellement socialement
culturellement j'ai bougé j'aime bien
lire dans beaucoup de langues écouter
des audiolivre voir des films rencontrer
les amis et participer dans des cultures
donc pour moi ça vaut la peine mais
c'est pour chacun des idées des idées
donc troisième question est ce que c'est
en vaut la peine
donc si vous pouvez répondre oui ces
trois questions
vous allez devenir quelqu'un que vous
allez pouvoir apprendre une autre langue
et apprendre à parler cette vente une
façon courant d'eau couramment merci
beaucoup de la tante de l'écouté de
l'écouté
merci beaucoup au revoir